Liberalism
emphasizes individual freedom
as a fundamental principle.
It is based on the belief that
each individual has rights
natural and organic
that must be protected by the state.
These rights include freedom of expression,
of thought,
of association and private property.
Assisted by a limited state
to protect these rights
and promote equal opportunities,
encouraging free competition in the economy.
Considers that government intervention
must be minimal
to enable individual and social development,
relying on people's capabilities
to self-govern
and make decisions in their own interest,
as long as
do not interfere with the rights of other individuals.